post factum after the uh after the
moment of grasping christ they said
weren't our hearts burning within us
he was speaking to us on the road
opening the scriptures to us just as he
opened the eyes he opened the scriptures
but this this tells us that
something has been happening all along
and he's been working on them
unbeknownst to them yeah to me this is
absolutely fascinating because you have
to assume if christ is in that state of
intense luminosity imperceptible to
their eyes
that this
working in them
this fire burning in them
is of the same
kind
um
and this is in fact how our
how uh the early christian tradition
reads it
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everyone christ has risen we
are still in bright week and uh we
thought it would be a wonderful moment
to look at the story of the road to
emmaus and i'm very pleased to be with
father bogdan father bogdan bukur i'm
not sure is that's how you pronounce
your last name i'm sorry
and father bogdan teaches patriotistics
at saint vladimir seminary and
he he really suggested that we might
look at the story of the road to emmaus
to help us understand you know and
understand or
and turn around the mystery of the
resurrected christ kind of understand
how the church fathers especially center
from the syrian
and fathers like him interpret scripture
and what it means for us today as we
encounter the world around us so father
bogdan thanks for talking to me i'm
happy to meet you
thank you very much for having me
very excited about this
and so the story of the road to emmaus
is is of one of the very strange stories
in scripture and i pointed it
often i pointed at it often with people
who kind of asked me you know what does
the resurrection look like when someone
says when someone kind of takes for
granted that the resurrection is just a
dead body you know sitting up in the
grave and walking out i say well there's
stories in scripture that tend to want
to
to imply that there's much more going on
and the story of the disciples meaning
christ of the road to emmaus is
definitely one of them because they
don't recognize him then he kind of then
they recognize him you know and then
they take it's a commute it's communion
and it's all these things kind of coming
together in the story so tell us a
little bit about your own thoughts on
this on this very particular story in
scripture
well i'm
fascinated by it like like all of us
this is one of the uh one of the stories
that we
read cyclically
at matins at the morning service
on sundays
in the orthodox church and
we all read it
orthodox and non-orthodox christians or
non-christians as we read scripture i
always
fails to be um
how shall i put it open to interpret i
mean it is open interpretation but it
fails to be cracked yes thing that
always remains mysterious as you said
as the two disciples are leaving
and you have to wonder
why are they leaving why are they
leaving and the others are staying
behind so i suppose
they've had it uh they can't
can't deal with this anymore it's uh
they're grieving
and um
at the same time they must have been
very disappointed because
at some point they explain
that uh they thought
this might be a prophet they thought he
might even be the messiah and clearly
they no longer do
these are disciples who leave the
community who leave the disciples they
leave the center jerusalem and move
away
and
it's suddenly they're there with jesus
himself and they have no idea
uh that is the first the first thing is
how is it that they walk and talk with
jesus for some three hours from
jerusalem walking to emmaus
and not only do they have no idea that
it is jesus they even lecture jesus
about jesus they don't you don't know
what happened and they they talk down to
him
you're the only stranger has no clue
about all these things that have
happened
even they even give him a sort of
primer on uh christology which is a
faulty christology basically
he could have been the messiah but it
wasn't
and um and so that's the first thing
how is it that they don't they don't
understand secondly
um how is it that um after talking down
to him for a while
they start to listen
and then they become
so fascinated let's say
by him that they they they don't want to
part and they ask him and urge him to
stay with them
and they defer to him he is the one who
actually
presides at the the meal that they want
to have with him
and somehow suddenly their eyes are
opened whatever that means because
earlier it said their eyes were held
from beh from from recognizing him
that's also mysterious you know who was
holding their eyes their own weakness
god satan something else
and suddenly now their eyes are opened
in the breaking of the bread
as he
as he performs this their eyes are open
fine but then he disappears
and so
now again mysterious why does he vanish
and does he go away does he not go away
does he go away from their side or does
he remove himself what does that mean
and they return why do they return now
with much greater energy and with the
proclamation of the resurrection
so this entire story i find um
uh even though i don't think we're going
to understand it fully maybe that's the
whole point
i mean the resurrection is something
that
is somehow already but not yet
yeah this interim um this tension is
itself what we uh
where we are that's why i like it yeah
and and there's something i think that
in order to understand it the way that i
would tend to approach it would be
to look at the other stories that are
parallel to this one and so you have
the story of course of saint mary of
saint mary magdalene who has a similar
interaction with the risen christ but
then i think this also goes
all the way to pentecost in terms of a
pattern which is the pattern of the
disciples that don't know what's going
on that are
that are sad that are you know they're
hiding there's something and then
there's a revelation they receive a
revelation which makes them understand
what this was all about let's say from
from the outset
and i think that you know i think you
also see that in the story of doubting
thomas as well there's something of that
as well where thomas doubts he doesn't
know and then there's a revelation which
reveals a risen christ to him so it
seems that the pattern is there
in the rotometers is very striking
because of the way
it's patterned but it seems to be all
going all all this goes together
and
the talking to strangers i think is
important because it's there also in the
the story of uh pentecost that is moving
away from the center kind of forgetting
or not knowing the reason anymore not
understanding the reason for
why we were together what we were doing
and suddenly discovering it as a
surprise
in the uh
in the strain in in in the strange world
like the fish the the story of the fish
in scripture has something to do with
that or saint peter finding the gold
coin in the fish's mouth like moving out
towards the ocean and suddenly being
surprised by revelation there seems to
be all that kind of going on in this
this particular story this is
just the frame of of the story
is a story of conversion literally of
turning around because they move away
and then they return they abandon the
the community of disciples
and they return as disciples in fact as
better disciples than the ones who had
not left perhaps these are more honest
disciples honestly honest with their
with their doubts with their uh grief um
so when they return they return uh as
bearing good news to the to the ones
that remain
it's a wonderful story also um
to where in which you can see
how christ deals with uh with these
people because he doesn't mind going in
the wrong direction apparently away from
jerusalem
in order to gain them in order to
be able to to return them so it's a
large a long loop really
that he doesn't mind taking with them
um and incidentally another another um
story let's say um
that connects with this is in the gospel
of mark uh specialists call it longer
ending of mark
it's an addition to the gospel of mark
in which
somebody who must have had access to uh
to the gospel of luke
uh says two of them were walking in the
countryside
and they met him
he walked with them in another form
and
this is one perhaps the earliest attempt
to
to interpret all these mysteries or give
some kind of a key what this
what this uh in another form might mean
perhaps uh uh remain i mean i suppose
it's to do
with a connection between the
resurrection appearance of christ and
what luca told us about the
transfiguration because he's the only
one who speaks about a different
appearance a different form
it is
very mysterious
yeah that's an interesting it's an
interesting
idea there's something also
which is fascinating when i think about
it iconographically the idea of
encountering christ in a different form
it's something that to a certain extent
this is going to sound strange because
it's we take taken so much for granted
that it it's actually going to be hard
to think about but the way that we
represent christ in icons is actually as
a roman nobleman that's how we represent
christ we don't represent christ as a
as a first century
rabbi or teacher and so there is
something even in our iconographic
representation of christ which is
something of the stranger that is there
is in our the way we show it show him
that he is
that he is something of that stranger
that you encounter the surprise of the
encounter of something which is not
which is not in its original form and so
we're so used to it that we don't think
about it but yeah do you mind if i show
you an image yes go ahead what's your
thought over it um this is an image that
uh um that i actually saw um on mount
arthur's um
in careers uh so this is this um image
of uh christ in another form
um as you can see he doesn't look like
like the christ we know
in most icons i think
and the whole point i mean i don't find
anything
peculiar except that it doesn't look
like him but maybe that's the entire
the entire point um
what is the context of this image where
where is it in the uh in the uh
processes the the
over the table of ablation where the
gifts are prepared
in in church um and
it doesn't have a any kind of prominence
there i was fascinated to uh
to find it there uh this is not my
photograph i found a better one online
stole it from there
but this is uh this is the only
the only uh
the only
image i
know of
in which you would have something
special otherwise i've seen christ and
the two disciples on the road and
there's nothing but peculiar about it
um
but since you mentioned uh mary
magdalene in the garden
um
how about this one
uh
because it seems to me leaving aside the
iconographic uh technique or the the
painting technique i i can tell us
something about this but
as far as i can uh see one obvious
element interpretive element here
is that even though we are not sold
not in the store of a mouse not in the
store of magdalene meeting christ in the
garden we are not told that christ is
luminous
or if he's luminous it's not the kind of
luminosity that would have been
perceived by them
i i can say a few things about that
in a moment but
in the icon he is rendered where
this isn't really an icon anymore
this is an in-between right uh yeah this
renaissance painting
um but here he is luminous and
in fact that's what strikes me um
how should we
paint this how should we render it
and you're i think
there seems to be definitely a a
reference to
the transfiguration in the way that
christ is represented here
um because this is usually the way that
we think of christ and the
transfiguration as being luminous
and so relating that the the
resurrection to the transfiguration is
obviously not
not a very big leap it's not something
that is it's something that intuitively
seems to to connect quite easily
um and so it seems that that's and but
there's also something so mysterious
about that moment when christ
you know what is he what is he saying
and he's saying don't touch me because
not yet it's like not yet i'm not yet
and it's not totally clear what that
what what that implies
well on the road to emails it's um it's
um it's different because uh
he allows himself to be to be um
to to be interacted with
and yet there is
a veil
uh since luke says their eyes were held
so that they would not recognize him and
um some have suggested
well maybe their own uh
their own problems their own sinfulness
uh maybe satan
but usually this way of phrasing things
in in scripture is uh hinting at
um an act of god
god
holding their eyes so that they would
not
they would not um be overwhelmed maybe
they are not in a position in a state
that would allow them to understand more
than they do
and it's it takes a journey
and it takes christ's
it says that he's interpreting to them
in all the scriptures but we're not told
which scriptures all the scriptures all
the things about himself
that remains also somewhat ambiguous
and
their eyes are not open then
but it takes the completion of the
journey the meal
the breaking of the bread and then
everything suddenly comes together and
then
their eyes were opened again it's
in this passive that that hints at god
opening their eyes just as god had kept
them
from recognizing him and they knew him
but they cannot sustain this vision
um just as an as a parallel i think you
and i have
must have the same experience that pasca
is
yeah uh climax and then
and then you're you can't sustain you
can't hold on to it
it's not just pasca it's every time you
take communion it's like you know you go
up and you take communion and you you
have this moment of
you know you enter into the mystery and
then a few days later you know you're
thinking about your taxes or your
whatever you're fighting with your wife
and you're like
oh you know it's like wow none of this
is
it's not holding but but maybe that's us
actually i think that the idea of
understanding this as an initiation is
possibly one of the ways to see it which
is that it seems to parallel
the actual structure of the liturgy
itself which is you know the the liturgy
where we actually have the the epistle
and the gospel and then we have
we move towards communion and that also
seems to mark the way the catechumens
were brought into the church as well
taught the scripture at first and then
revealed the mystery where they would
enter into communion in the end
at in the after they were baptized and
so i'm wondering if there isn't there is
an initia initiatory
suggestion in this story as well
well um
certainly i i can bring in um
i can bring in um send ephraim um
a little bit of help from saint from
mites
it's always helpful yes uh and by the
way
this is the book where i'm taking it
from
it's well well well well worth
purchasing
um
ephraim's hymns on paradise he has a few
reference there you might wonder
what does paradise have to do with all
of this
but if you're
thinking a bit we say we have
no way of approaching paradise just as
we have no way of approaching
the risen state in which christ finds
himself and the resurrection towards
which
we are we're being called um we can only
speak with the language of of ritual i
suppose let me show you um
i'll share screen again
to show you a couple of of texts from
saint afram
all right so first he says that uh
when moses
speaks about the structure
of the um of the intent of meeting and
later to be to be
uh
the temple same structure
he marks a difference between these two
rooms the holy place and the holy of
holies
with the way we have in our churches at
the nave and then the the altar area
and the tree of knowledge is placed
as a gate
by which one would have access to the
holy of holies to the altar area
and god did not permit adam to enter
into that tabernacle
not because
not because the tree of knowledge would
be would be bad or the fruit of it would
be bad god does not make bad things but
first he has other things to do
um he has to taste of the other things
he has to prove himself
a well-functioning priest because adam
is a sort of priest there his sensing
etc he has the taste of the other trees
of virtues presumably
um
and
this then
um
he says
uh this thing doesn't work
properly because adam
learned that the tree of knowledge
served as a veil for the sanctuary
and realized that its fruit
was the key of justice that would open
the eyes of the bold
and
he makes bold and and partakes
and he and eve have their eyes opened
but at the same time closed so as not to
see the glory of the inner tabernacle
now
saint uh ephraim then connects this with
the disciples on the road to emmaus
and says that when there when the
disciples eyes were clo were closed
red was the key
now when we say that bread was the key
it's obvious that uh saint ephrem and
and many many others in our tradition in
fact
understand that meal uh at emmaus to
have been a eucharistic meal yeah and
bread is the key that opens their eyes
and now
their eyes behold a vision of joy and
are filled with happiness
and so there's this ambiguity if
properly received
it grants access it feels one with joy
it is what god intends for us
but if improperly partaken of in
disobedience and
and definitely from the wrong provider
you know if you think of adam and eve
then their eyes are saddened um
adam is called the cursed one
it's not um it's not at all as it should
be
um
so
to uh
to to recap
um in a way the um
the emails uh
meal
is um
how should i put it in in an in an
antithetical parallelism
with the partaking of the fruit in
paradise and resurrection is the undoing
of the fall into mortality in paradise
for saint ephrem this is nothing novel
in fact he's not these hymns are not uh
are not trying to say anything new he's
uh
he's
giving poetic uh
expression to something that is the
common tradition yeah
and there's something even in the way
that san fran presents it which which
almost
suggests that
in a certain manner the eucharist is the
way to access the tree of knowledge
properly if
this is actually a return to the
guardian and a partaking of the fruit
even the fruit that was forbidden but
done in a way which is not
through this kind of arrogant boldness
but through humility and receiving and
through sacrifice because that is how
christ brought that meal to us through
self-sacrifice
and the disciples in fact if you
if we read the story of the disciples
um as a story of as a
i shall be a pattern
of
any christian's discipleship
it is a road that leads from arrogance
to humility
they start by lecturing jesus yeah
you know they accuse him of not knowing
what had happened when in fact who is it
that doesn't know it's it's them they
don't know they don't know who they're
talking to they don't know who christ is
they don't know that the women
had indeed spoken the truth they don't
know anything
um but gradually
this arrogance is is um diluted more and
more and they listen more and more
and
i suppose this is part of what leads
what enables them
to see even for a fraction of a second
but that is enough that moment
is is so
so powerful so overwhelming
that it is indeed fully transformative
same with us and by the way what do we
say after we receive communion
we have seen the true light
and i don't know about you but
i can't say that i actually have seen it
with my eyes or in any other way though
i do believe we have seen it because we
wouldn't we wouldn't say
such things even though they're
quite a bit
more than than than our experience
allows us to to uh to grasp it is a
reality that
we do receive light
invisible to us
i have something i'd like to show you um
yeah about about the email story um this
is the thing that actually i think
connects
the gospel account with um
with its environment if first century uh
judaism
um
there is
there is a first century judaism a way
of understanding
what happened to moses moses is also
luminous when he comes from uh from
sinai when he comes down from the
mountain right
well
what we read in
scripture is that moses uh moses was so
overwhelmingly luminous
that the
fellow his fellow israelites were were
afraid of him
he was luminous the scripture says
because he had been speaking with god in
god's luminosity had been
rubbing off on him as it were
well it so happens that there is um
uh we have a text from
roughly uh the first century
palestine
in which
this episode is retold
uh it's a sort of rewritten bible it's a
genre of
of writing
that uh as the name says it retells
biblical events
but this is how we know how people would
have understood those things the way in
which we retell something uh colors it
well in one of these retellings
um
which is in the uh in a book called the
book of biblical antiquities from the
first century as i said this episode is
rendered in the following way
moses came down from sinai
having been bathed with light
invisible
the light of his face surpassed the
splendor of the sun and the moon but he
was unaware of it
so far it's pretty much what the bible
says just in different words but then
when he came to the children of israel
when they saw him they did not recognize
him they did not know him
but when he spoke to them then they
recognized him
and so
the strange thing is
it doesn't say that they perceived him
as being luminous they did not see him
luminous
they had no clue it was him moses
um and they were afraid
and they recognized him when he spoke to
them just as in the episode of mary
magdalene yeah say that he's luminous as
we've seen in the uh in the painting
uh by jyoto
but it says that she does not recognize
him until he speaks to her
then he then she recognizes him
and in the same book of biblical
antiquities the same episode i mean the
same notion let's put it of
not being able to recognize somebody
occurs in the case of david
the other great figure
in the hebrew bible
david
is about to slay goliath
um they i mean the king knows who david
is he sends him out it's unlikely that
he's going to accomplish anything what
is he going to do
this little boy he goes
um you know the story and when he's
about to to cut off goliath's head
he pour
the book of biblical antiquity says he
poses for a moment
and tells
tells goliath look up and see
who it is it slays you
and goliath looks up and says
that he sees his face like the face of a
son of god
and in other words this is unfair
because he's not been fighting uh some
israelite but there is something with
him he's being assisted as it were he
gets some kind of heavenly assistance
he slays him and then comes back to the
troops and nobody recognizes who david
is once again
say he's luminous
as goliath had said he saw him luminous
but they don't recognize him until he
speaks to them and then suddenly they do
recognize him
so i suppose that uh when saint luke
tells us about
about not recognizing christ
he's using this kind of tradition that
assumes that
in this state in which christ finds
himself and the disciples do not the
state of the resurrection
similarly to the transfiguration he is
in a different aspect
but this is not perceived by people who
are not capable of that who our
ascetical tradition would say not worthy
but it
it is effective this this presence this
light is effective
in creating this kind of um
confusion or um
people who don't who who are not
compatible with that state
uh yeah would not benefit from it in
fact would be harmed are held
from from recognizing
this person
so there's a
strange kind of
strength no i i think i i mean i yeah
but i think the tradition makes sense in
terms of
this is just phenomenologically
even the the
because we think that people's faces are
are obvious or just recognizing someone
is is an obvious thing but it's actually
it's not as obvious as you might think
there we have a
we have a story you know we have a
connection we have a part of us which
which recognizes the familiar
and
it is actually possible it's happened to
me where
this is on the opposite side of the
glorious one which is that i've
forgotten who someone is you know i
haven't seen them in several years and
then i encounter them and i don't
recognize them until they speak and when
they speak suddenly their face changes
in front of me like their their physical
attributes actually transforms because
my mind is putting them back together to
the person that i know and i can see
this person i recognize in them and so
this is of course has nothing to do with
transfiguration but
this you could understand that a being
that is is in this elated state that is
in a very high spiritual state
that that they would be transcending
their
particular face you could say and that
it would it would be difficult to
recognize them
so it doesn't seem that weird for me
that that would happen
i suppose it's not so much or not only
not only the
the stories that we have um but perhaps
broadly in the case of christ and the
disciples
the gestures
the breaking of the bread the
familiarity of that meal
first meal that that begins all these
meals that the risen christ has with the
disciples which we continue
in our liturgy
these are our meals
um but also what came before they um
the putting together uh they put it very
nicely you put together all these uh
elements that that make the face that
you recognize uh
recomposing as it were the um
the portrait the icon of the messiah
from all
all those elements that he finds in
scripture
and he he he interpreted all the things
about himself in all the scriptures and
suddenly they recognize the scriptural
christ
and that gets superimposed upon
the figure of the stranger that is with
them
who becomes to them not a stranger but a
teacher not a teacher but a friend
and then
everything gets
put in focus suddenly in that moment of
epiphany uh at the meal
it's the structure that we have also as
you as you said it's initiatory it is
gradual it is liturgical and this is how
we in fact do it we read the scriptures
we interpret the scriptures
we pray
and we partake and then say we have seen
the true light
uh i think this is the the pattern
indeed that we still have and
are capable of benefiting from if if we
so want to yeah and there's there's
something there's something fractally
true about that structure which is that
it reaches its
height in the liturgy and it is like the
liturgical and the the the sacramental
version of this of this pattern is the
is in a way the
the source of all the pattern but it's
also the way that you pretty much learn
about anything
right it's the way that you learn about
anything you know yet first you
you you you look at things everything
looks disparate you don't see the
pattern you don't see how things connect
you know you're if you're
learning about history at first it's all
facts nothing seems to kind of come
together if you're learning about uh any
skill even that you want to learn it all
at first it's confusing you don't
understand it then you start to tame it
things start to to accumulate and
accumulate finally you
it snaps together things snap and then
you can see the higher form
coming back down to to govern it you
could say and so i think that it's
actually the experience of learning
anything learning to cook learning to uh
but that christ reveals that pattern in
its highest form as how
the creation itself exists how the world
itself exists through through through
this initiatory uh
initiatory pattern we could say but one
needs a guide i mean the disciples the
disciples have to have a teacher they do
but they also have to recognize
themselves as disciples
and to function as such this is a beauty
i think of of this story it's also the
story of shaping them back into
into being disciples
and this is i think how it also connects
with with genesis
because some elements there i
are
certainly
deliberate in other words
that you have
that you have a state of not knowing
followed by a state of knowing it can be
it can be the wrong kind of knowing they
they adam and eve knew
that they were naked
or empty uh a jewish and christian
tradition uh
would say that they
were naked of the garment of glory
that they had had previously in other
words they don't
they don't realize they had been naked
all along and now they're ashamed of it
though this is the text on its surface
but nobody reads and takes on its
surface uh not in
not in judaism not in christianity uh in
traditional christianity that is um but
the
the understanding would have been
and is
that the they were clothed in a garment
of glory irradiate ear
irradiating
irradiating light
from inside out in that sense they're
clothed with it and they've they know
themselves naked of it suddenly
whereas with the disciples at the exact
opposite they knew christ
and
they have just received
the eucharist
he is there and they have also partaken
of him they have also partaken of him in
the exegesis of scripture which is a
self exegesis christ interpreted things
of himself
scriptures so there is this this uh
parallel the opening of the eyes which
is exactly the same adam and eve eyes
are opened uh cleopas and his his
companion their eyes are opened um
so that's why i call it an antithetical
parallelism and
the the main difference is that
they are very bad disciples in paradise
right i mean they
they
listen to the the wrong kind of teacher
right who says
god told you no
i'll give you the shortcut right the
cliff's notes to uh doing this
cheating on the exam basically whereas
these disciples
learn how to how to trust how to listen
um how to part how to commune with
christ
and therefore so that's my point is that
everything you said plus
the this relationship of discipleship
which is an absolute must yeah and it's
and it really is if you see it as this
antithetical pattern it really is a
return
to paradise that's what they're
experiencing at that moment you know
it's there there are many places in
scripture where christ operates that
pattern of a return to paradise but this
is one which is which is very powerful
and clear and links it to how the church
will then
continue that tradition like you said in
terms of discipleship in terms of
sacramental participation in terms of
catechum in it all of this is continued
on in the tradition of the church you
know and and the the story of the
disciples going to emmaus is the
the narrative version of what we now do
liturgically all the time basically
there is um
there's also
a strange element that
the disciples seem to
get all kinds of things
retrospectively
that is after christ vanishes from their
sight
um
and i think we should emphasize the fact
that he doesn't go
away
to vanish does not mean that he left
them
he vanishes from their sight no they
can't see him anymore exactly so
just as in liturgy we have seen the true
light way we might not have grasped it
but it was there and it is there
um
so also with the disciple he vanishes
from their sight is present but
invisibly present
but after after that
they have another little chat among
themselves this time it's not
about the the crushing uh trauma that
they had experienced with the
crucifixion this time
it's about their experience on the road
on the road it doesn't say in the text
that they would have
experienced anything special i mean they
don't
reflect then but
post factum after the after the
moment of grasping christ they said
weren't our hearts burning within us
he was speaking to us on the road
opening the scriptures to us just as he
opened the eyes he opened the scriptures
but this this tells us that
something has been happening all along
and he's been working on them
unbeknownst to them yeah to me this is
absolutely fascinating because you have
to assume if christ is in that state of
intense luminosity imperceptible to
their eyes
that this
working in them
this fire burning in them
is of the same
kind
um
and this is in fact how our
how uh the early christian tradition
reads it
and and there's something there are so
many ver i have all these versions of
that story that are just kind of
rushing into me because
you see in the story of the ethiopian
eunuch you see a similar situation where
the ethiopian eunuch is reading
scripture it doesn't understand it he's
confused he has no idea and then
you know philip comes and and and shows
him
you know which leads to sacrament which
leads to now not to the communal meal
but to the baptism and after the baptism
he vanishes too it's like he brings him
into the sacrament that he vanishes and
and the and the you know the eunuch is
left
in that state you could say a tran a
transformed state so it's interesting to
see that def this is definitely
something which which is part of of uh
of the resurrected and the body of how
the body of christ works let's say after
the resurrection and it also shows in
the same way
this uh discipleship chain of command
because
the eunuch reads he just doesn't know
what it means who he's reading about in
isaiah 53 how to put things together and
it takes the guidance of philip
but philip himself
doesn't know about this
until he's prompted
by it's not very clear there uh it's
this holy spirit or it's an angel or
that's another person maybe um but he's
receiving from above let's say yes
exactly yes that's right so he's
received from above
the impulse to go and do this and philip
could have said
not now later not this way not the
ethiopian
whatever the kind of things that you
have plenty of in scripture like moses
go but what if pharaoh but what if the
israelites
send somebody else
it doesn't always work so easily
with philip who is a disciple it works
easily
go
he goes tell him he tells him and the
ethiopian eunuch benefits from it it's a
kind of a chain of command if you want
but it's not to lord it over god lording
it over philip philip lording it over
the of the unit it's to serve and to
empower and to to help
uh achieve god's god's um goal
in all these folks and
indeed this is this is um how it works
um
yeah the the light is carried down
and moses is the same it's the same
thing most goes up the mountain he
receives from god and then he comes down
and then brings to the level that each
person is able to receive it down the
mountain all the way to the bottom you
know and you see you know this idea and
saying it's a maximus that you know all
things participate into in the glory of
god to the to the extent that they that
they can in their in their being and
that appears as this chain this grand
chain of light that comes down and and
and fills the world ultimately and so
and like you said the christian version
of that is has something to do with gift
and sacrifice and self-sacrifice giving
ourselves down to that which is below
the father that gives himself for his
children and for his wife rather than
the way that that authority is
understood in a in a more kind of brutal
pagan way where it's just it's just a
basic control of people that are below
it's a different form of hierarchy well
we're told
how god's authority works it works
by washing the feet of the disciples
um
i want to show these uh these texts
about
how the fathers understood
well this burning of the heart there's
this burning heart
because it it really goes to the um to
the heart of our um especially the
ascetical tradition though
that ascetical tradition is the common
uh the common inheritance of all
regardless of how much of which uh one
practices with one monastic or
monastic or
um
but the fascinating thing is that uh
it seems to be um it seems to be
um
how should i put it
a um
a unanimous way of of reading um
so i have three authors and they're all
important one is origin
um great
teacher um
yes some some heresies and some
problematic things but also
the one author that everybody reads
and benefits from after him sin basil
the great who read origin
of course corrected him to but benefited
from him and the mccarran homilies the
fifth homilies
so origen says that um
like earthly fire
with its double action burning and
giving light spiritual fire is also
double in nature
it is the light that enlightens every
man
but it is also the eternal fire prepared
for the devil and his angels
and so there isn't really an essential
difference between
say the light of paradise
and the fires of gehenna
the difference is simply in the way in
which we
relate to the presence of god but it is
the presence of god yeah um it was he
says it was the same christ that burned
the hearts of the disciples on the road
to emmaus
and enlightened them by the opening to
them by opening to them the scriptures
now why are their eyes held
because
they're not capable yet of sustain that
vision
in a way that is safe for them
so they're slowly being
purified you know burned in the hearts
as it were to make that heart less uh
less sclerotic uh in fact this is what
christ says your hearts are dull your
hearts are slow you're slow of heart
um
ants in basil then starts to find these
references in scripture
what sort of what sort is this fire
which purges sins
the
sons of aarons the brother of moses were
burned up having used an alien fire but
the seraph
took a live call from the holy fire that
was on the noetic the spiritual altar of
the true whole burn offerings in the old
testament isaiah the prophet receives
from the seraph
uh this kind of purification
enable him to stand in the presence of
god
because he says when he sees god you can
read this in isaiah chapter six he sees
god and he's horrified woe is me
i'm a man of unclean lips and i i'm i'm
here well the the seraph takes a live
call
and purifies him
akin to this fire was also the fire of
the thorn bush that moses saw and then
the heart of cleopas and simon was
burning with such a fire when the lord
was expounding to them the scriptures
um and he gives other examples as well
so the point is this is not some
metaphor of
some emotion um you know stirring up
stirring them up it's not
it's not some kind of conceptual light
bulb that uh that
goes on
it is something that is
god's very presence god's very presence
um transformative
and finally this is the i think that the
the most impressive text um sid mcarious
or suramar karis it's not really
macarius some anonymous author
given the name in tradition of macarius
but the 50 spiritual homilies
say
basically put together all scripture
references that you have to fire and so
forth i've selected a few
our god is a consuming fire and this
fire exerted its power over the apostles
when they spoke with tongues of fire at
pentecost
this fire surrounded paul in the voice
that enlightened his mind while blinding
his senses when paul meets the risen
christ on the road to uh to damascus
this fire appeared to moses in the bush
this fire caught up elijah
when he is taken up from the earth and
this fire inflamed the heart of cleopas
and his companion when the savior spoke
to them after the resurrection
this fire burns up the beam of the
interior eyes this fire drives up demons
and has the power of the resurrection
and this is really this passage here
the last one that i've read
travels as such
in the in the tradition the jessica's
tradition the tradition of uh of um
prayer that purifies and leads to the
vision of god as light and it becomes
it becomes a set
text that travels
in the manuscripts and the point is that
our little verse there about lucas and
cleopas oclopus and his unnamed
companion
is a witness to this experience
and so when we're reading a story that
is
somewhat ambiguous and mysterious and um
fascinating at the same time but it is
not a story that is inaccessible to us
in its in its reality that reality is
not only accessible to us but
definitely for us we must
in other words at least embark with the
disciples i guess the same
road
yeah that's that's i think that's
wonderful and uh you know i think that
uh you know i think that that's actually
probably a good place for us to to to
finish the conversation as a
encouragement for people to uh
to understand the light of the
resurrection as something which is
really the presence of god which is
accessible to us through through the
church of the sacraments through through
also this encounter with christ that we
can all have access to you know in our
heart which is the good way to describe
it and so
father bogdan thank you so much for your
wisdom and your thoughts on this much
for your time uh and uh i'm very much
looking forward to maybe receiving you
so thoughts privately about the
iconography of this all right definitely
we can we can definitely do that all
right
thank you
christ has risen indeed he's risen
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate
by you know buying things that i've
designed t-shirts with different designs
on them and you can also support this
podcast and these videos through paypal
or through patreon everybody who
supports me has access to an extra video
a month and there are also all kinds of
other goodies and tiers that you can get
involved with so everybody thank you
again and thank you for your support